merci d'être avec nous et à l'aube à
basse et le lundi fac bonnes fêtes de
pâques à tous mais l'on sait que c'est
une fête très très important vraiment on
ans mais c'est vrai c'est une fête
importante j'espère que vous avez été
chercher des deux mois je vais chercher
des hommes et enfants tous les os tous
les ans normalement voilà les chéris
aujourd'hui on va découvrir des talents
puisque tout le monde va jouer vous
allez jouer chez violette est ce que tu
peux nous faire le cri de la mouette
vas-y c'est ce à quoi et avec ça tu es
champion du monde se fout de notre
gueule
dimitri est ce que tu peux nous dire
comment tu lis dans le couscous
je l'avais des pois chiches ouais la
semoule
ouais je le torti avec la merguez
ouais bah ça j'arrive à voir ce qui va
se passer le lendemain je mettrai tu vas
te [ __ ] de notre gueule encore qu'on a
le temps il ya deux personnes qui font
des live c'est benoît paire et stanislas
wawrinka pendant leur live j'ai comme le
sentiment qui moi un petit peu charrié
cci la nina qui m'assurent foetale
heures sur quoi aubanel
parce qu'en fait on faisait idée le truc
le 3 que j'ai fait là du coup on s'est
parlé vite fait ni au pad à la faune ils
pensent qu'ils aient pensé diom stan
j'ai eu l'impression avec benoît paire
que vous étiez un petit peu en train de
me charrier concernant mes capacités
tennistiques et mes capacités de paddle
benoît paire et là je sais lui pour moi
s'est levé le principal accusé qu'est
mon frère on vise à répondre à ce jeu-là
répondre à ça en fait
vas-y moi je pense qu on ne charrie pas
forcément pour bon niveau qui je ne
connais pas ton niveau mais ta façon de
faire une fois une chaude et tout de
suite penser que tel
rappelle-toi rappelle toi chez toi quant
à lui remis les pas de l'ads avec les
voitures comme s'est battu non alors je
vais vous dire la vérité on a il n'y
avait pas de lumière chez moi on a dû
aller dehors mettre la table dehors et
allumer les phares de la voiture pour
voir la balle et benoît tout dans tout
ça tout ça t'a bon tout ça ta bouche
point les téléspectateurs à témoins mais
benoît frère c'est moi qui ai gagné et
il y avait deux témoins il y avait un
copain mois qui s'appelle franck que je
peux appeler tout de suite et on avait
appelé quelqu'un tout de suite après sa
défaite et sept personnes et la voie à
ces rythmes a appelé tout de suite après
ces résultats je vient d'éclater benoît
est bien mais arrêtez arrêtez de noir au
thème tu as perdu tu as perdu
moi ce que je trouve composer c'est
qu'après le confinement on fasse un
double
gaël et moi au paddle tennis contre stan
et benoît on retransmet sur ces mythes
ont fait de dire du public et on donne
tout la recette pour l'association des
hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france en
pleine semaine de pâques donc on va pas
faire les bois boîte mon affaire les no
les no 9 de ba ba et pour jouer avec
nous il y à celui qui me manque le plus
voilà je vous le dis c'est mon julien
courbet qui étaient avec nous qui va
jouer pour les hôpitaux de paris
hôpitaux de france ça va mon jus d'amour
à l'humour sert il et comment saveurs et
ben ça va mon chéri ça me fait plaisir
d'avoir de tes nouvelles alertes a l'air
en forme donc ça me va et on a avec nous
abbas et emeline qui va jouer avec no
mercy emeline tu nous appelles des
yvelines et d'1 de dunkerque d'actes
alors qu'elle m'a fait un accent du sud
m'a dunkerque c'est magnifique c'est la
seule famille de dakar avec un accent du
sud
je dis tu nous appelles 2002 dan care
c'est la fille de rené malleville en
fait rien à voir il reste 2 1 9 à 5
euros à 9 à 50 millions on me dit qu'il
ya une dernière proposition de notre
charcutier trader je propose de couper
le 102
je vous propose 10 villes euros dix
mille euros je sais pas comment ils
coupent en 2006 le très dur je sais pas
comment il a coupé l'enfant deux parce
que 50000 ça fait cinquante cinq mille
son couple fandos a fait 29500 alors ses
10000 euros chacun bien sûr et 20 mille
dangers des 10000 euros chacun oui mais
ça fait vingt mille mercis à l'est
merzouk donc merzouk proposera un mille
euros en tout donc ce qui ferait dix
mille pour emeline et 10000 pour la
fondation des hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux
de france
je vais garder au web les sages
décisions et mini tu gagnes
dix mille euros ma chérie tu gagnes
10000 euros et me fixer purell la
semaine dernière dans l'émission on
avait reçu donc jacques charles fombonne
le président de l'ajs père la société
protectrice des animaux et il avait tenu
à délivrer un message de sensibilisation
sur la situation des refuges en cette
période de confinement et visiblement
son message a été entendu puisque à
partir du 16 avril une tolérance sera
accordée dans les déplacements malgré le
confinement pour les personnes
souhaitant adopter un animal on refuse
que je voudrais vous remercier tous les
médias nous ont aidés tout le monde
s'est occupé de nous mais vous tirez
vous avez été particulièrement
bienveillants je sais que j'avais relayé
beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux et ont
donc des milliers d'animaux vous avez ce
plu nous avons sauvé avec vous je
voulais vous remercier
vraiment merci d'être avec nous d'amidon
merci pour votre invitation je suis aidé
nos papiers père je suis la déléguée
générale de la fondation de paris
hôpitaux de france et je tenais au nom
de l'ensemble de la fondation et de
notre président je m'accroche à vous
dire un immense merci pour tout ce que
vous avez fait depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant dans votre émission sourire
et toute l'équipe helmand pour
accompagner notre action dans le cadre
il ya pas mal de gens aussi qui
réfléchissent à leur vie j'ai
l'impression pendant ce confinement et
qu'ils istèque j'ai fait des erreurs je
referai pas peut-être pas la même chose
c'est aussi le temps aussi de réfléchir
un peu j'ai l'impression même même jean
miquel toiture mita d'état des regrets
toit de ce que tu penses à des trucs
pendant ce que parce que tu te dis j'ai
des choses que je n'aurais pas dû faire
est-ce que tu regrettes des trucs dans
ta vie là on serait qu on déconne mais
c'est des trucs aussi qu'on a envie de
se dire est convoqué et qu'on se marre
franchement c'est pas tellement par
rapport aux à ma vie amoureuse c'est ce
que je pense qu'on a que ce qu'on mérite
quelque part donc je pense que si je
suis célibataire aujourd'hui c'est
quelque part j'ai bien cherché circo
voilà j'ai été instable j'ai fait des
conneries
donc j'ai mérité qu'on petit voilà où
tous ceux qui t'ont ça je me plains pas
de ça même si j'espère toujours
retrouver un grand amour mes romans je
réfléchis plutôt assure ma vie de ma vie
par an voilà j'ai été assez présent de
papa pas été assez présent et mes
enfants et je pense particulièrement ce
moment ce que je dois pas parce que je
veux parler de risque et décontaminer
fut donc je les vois pas et le
bâle la période me pèse en plus mes
enfants mais qui pour coup et je me dis
que voilà c'était passé à côté de
quelque chose de très important et ça je
le regrette mais moi je t'ai vu avec les
enfants notamment ta fille j'ai
l'impression qu'elle n'en veut pas du
tout et qu'elle est hyper heureuse
d'être avec toi je la vois qu'elle
viendrait nous voir à l'émission
donc est ce que l'on peut reprocher mine
de rien n'était vrai nom mais justin
plus j'ai pression j'ai plus été absent
et mon fils parce que j'étais à ce
moment là je faisais pas télévision
j'étais aux filles à rosteig rampante
rgp souvent étrangers j'étais pas là ebi
j'ai un petit je suis parti d'un ring
acquis la villa il a 26 ans il a 26 ans
et voilà je trouve qu'il est parti du
principe un peu vieux que un garçon
c'est plus indépendant plus tu ce
rapidement c'est son envol alors que
voilà j'ai ma fille je suis tout le
temps je laime mais je pense qu'à mon
fils je n'ai jamais dit que je l'aimais
alors je pense évidemment je l'aimais
énormément mais je n'ai jamais dit
peut-être par pudeur comme j'ai dit à
mon père que je n'ai pas non plus il est
parti jusqu'à quand il était malade à
l'hôpital jeunes il faut que juriste que
j'aime et j'ai pas réussi à lui dire
qu'à paris c'est qu'il le savait j'ai
pareil je savais que je l'aimé mais j'ai
pas réussi à lui dire et tout ça
maintenant je sais qu'avec ma fille je
le corrige ça m'a fichu dont je laime
j'essaie de changer par les gens me jean
miss et c'est vraiment émouvant ce que
tu ce que tu nous racontes et 8 livres
et c'est pour ça que je t'aime
énormément mon mathieu touristes ou à
toi aussi tu as his ça te fait réfléchir
tout ça le le confinement tout ça ou pas
du tout bas beaucoup parce que tu te
rends compte qu'en fait chaque jour tu a
fui beaucoup de choses tu vas faire du
sport tu vas tu vas tu vas travailler tu
travailles jusqu'à neuf heures du soir
parce qu'en fait tu fuis tu puises tu
puis beaucoup de choses et quand tout à
coup tout s'arrête
batman en conscient de ce qui reste et
ce qui reste c'est qu'ils rien dire que
quand le travail s'arrête
bah tu te dis j'ai pas de famille gg
personne dans ma vie et j'ai raté une
autoroute quoi j'ai rien construit je
suis tout seul et c'est vrai que je
pense que c'est extrêmement important
d'y réfléchir parce que je me dis le
jour où marc ma carrière on peut dit
même on part qu'il s'arrêtera c'est le à
côté qui va me créer une stabilité et la
côte et il est nul donc effectivement
c'est très bien décider à s'acheter une
belle voiture et d'essais de gagner de
l'argent et de travailler mais je pense
que c'est pas ça le vrai truc sont
encore en train de réfléchir
actuellement c'est pas ça le vrai truc
je pense que la vraie réussite elle et
pas professionnel est de créer quelque
chose autour de soi et et je vois bien
que ça a été un échec total jusqu'à
maintenant